direct from earth one do you like my
face it's the face you were wearing when
I became the flesh I thought I'd put it
on again you know for old times sake
plus handsome I watched you die or did
you time travel very so very confusing I
always seem to be saying that do don't I
go on find it fine dad stopping meal ah
I forgot Barry Allen is above killing
isn't that right
[Music]
get out of here
I wonder what face I'll be wearing next
time we meet can't wait
[Music]
Gideon yes professor fun where the hell
am I
[Music]
he's being erased from existence
so what should we call this brave new
world that you've whipped up for us I
was thinking flashpoint there we go
things are back to how there should be
well for me anyway for you well I guess
you'll just have to wait and find out
[Music]
hey everybody so far and away the
biggest question I got after the big
crossover episode was how is it that
earth one reverse-flash was season 1 is
back harassing Barry but they're just a
couple key pieces of information that
the TV show has not told you yet that
explains how he can still be alive
given the events of season 1 2 3 of the
flash and season 2 of legends of
tomorrow because we've seen him die a
number of times but if you are finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're also
doing a new round of the flash ring
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video too so in order to understand
how reverse flash and time-travel works
you need to know two real big things one
that they've never fully explained the
rules of time travel in the arrowverse
in to when speedsters die without fail
they go back into the Speed Force as
pure energy no matter how they die they
go back into the Speed Force so like
when you see the reverse flash being
vaporized here at the end of season 1
and then later during legends of
tomorrow season 2 he's actually being
sucked up into the Speed Force so just
remember that as we go through his
timeline here so I'll explain what
happened to him along the way when Matt
Letcher went on legends of tomorrow last
season he actually said something funny
he's like don't hold them to the fire
too much on the rules of time-travel he
didn't say in quite so many words but he
was basically saying that the legends of
tomorrow riders were gonna mess around
with the reverse-flash character and
they weren't gonna worry too much about
what was going on with him on the flash
TV show in the same thing vice-versa for
the flash riders the flash riders
whenever they did reverse flash again
wouldn't have to pay too much attention
to what legends of tomorrow did with the
character which is a little frustrating
but it actually does work out if you
just remember those two rules that I
talked about primarily that when
speedsters die whether they're evil
they're good speedsters they just get
sucked back up into the Speed Force as
pure energy so every time the reverse
flash dies he just goes up into the
Speed Force until he can escape again
what that means is is that the reverse
flash that we saw during the course of
legends of tomorrow season two is a
completely different version of the
character so what happens is is at the
end of season 1 this version of the
reverse flash dies he gets
tucked back up into the speedforce when
we get to season two and we see him port
in looking for berry it's actually a
younger version of the character who
hasn't gone through the events of season
one yet he doesn't know where berry
lives in the timeline and he's just
looking for him he finds him then at the
end of that episode berry throws him
back into the future so that in his own
future he can come back to the night
that he killed Barry's mother do that
and set off the events of season one so
that all goes according to plan but then
you get to the end of season two and
berry goes back to create flashpoint so
the version that he's grabbing out of
the timeline and creating flashpoint
with is the version that we saw in
season two so by this point we're on a
completely different iteration of the
character in the season one version of
the reverse flash is still stuck in the
Speed Force as pure energy when they fix
flashpoint the second version of eobard
thawne tells Barry that everything's
fine for me but you're just gonna have
to wait and see which was more of a
teaser force avatar than anything else
so then he goes off to legends of
tomorrow but he reveals that he's
actually a time remnant version of the
character who should have been erased
when Eddie killed himself so this is
where they're trying to sew up their
logic he's a time remnant shouldn't
exist black flash eventually catches up
with him kills him and he gets sucked
back up into the Speed Force so the
reason why this is red instead of white
is because it's a completely different
version of the character so the thing
about the reverse flash and the thing
about time travel is that it takes a
while for changes to stick so when the
reverse flash says that he's always one
step ahead
he's literally one step ahead of time
waves but here's the thing to remember
the riders from each of the different
shows don't follow each other's rules a
hundred percent so when they brought
back this version of the reverse flash
and he pretty much said I'm the one from
season 1 Barry's like I saw you die so
just confirming which version it is it's
basically the flash riders saying that
that version that you saw on legends of
tomorrow is a completely different
iteration of the character so it's sort
of the writers room using the vagaries
of the way they've defined the rules of
time-travel in that they have not
defined any of the rules
and sweeping a lot of the legends of
tomorrow stuff under the rug like we saw
him die was a big moment on
b-but we're not gonna bring that version
of the character back that pretty much
confirms that the next time we see Matt
lecher come back and play eobard thawne
he'll be a different version than we've
seen before but a lot of that just
depends on where he comes from in how
much information he has usually that's
how you chart the reverse flashes
timeline is what does he remember what
does he know about Barry but based on
what he said at the end of the episode
it confirms that the next time we see
reverse-flash it will be this version of
the character just wearing a different
face and I think that might have
something to do with the actors in real
life like Tom Cavanagh plays him every
once in a while and it's really cool but
usually it helps to have another version
of the character so we might wind up
with a situation where he's either
masquerading as Barry or he's
masquerading as another evil speedster
like we could get max mercury it could
be the reverse flash wearing his face
the writers and the producers haven't
said anything about the next time
they're gonna bring him back it might be
towards the end of the season because
there's the whole tornado twins thing
that happened during the crossover which
I'll do a separate video for and that
seems like it's going to come back
around at the very end of the season so
there were just a couple things that
happened during these crossover episodes
where they're teasing plot points that
they won't pay off till future seasons
or the very very end of this season so
hopefully that explains a little bit
about how this version of the
reverse-flash can still be alive and
Eddie is still dead a lot of you are
asking when the black flash is going to
come back I'm not expecting him to come
back until we get a lot more speedster
type stories and that doesn't seem like
it's gonna be a thing until next season
in future seasons after that there is a
new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from my
Titans video infinity Jay please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for that
Titan season one Robyn teaser and you
can click here for my new infinity war
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight